in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Victor
is here hi Victor how are ya so we're
pretty good about yourself better than I
deserve sir welcome welcome here to do
your debt-free scream I assume yes sir
where are you from from the Knoxville
Tennessee area ah very cool very cool
our family's from there as well so
welcome to Nashville so how much data be
paid off sir
paid off about fifty thousand and twenty
two months why did it go
making what kind of money started at
twenty seven thousand went up to thirty
nine thousand all right excellent
excellent very cool what kind of debt
was this well thirty two of it was on a
car I know that sounds ridiculous for
somebody with a $27,000 a year income
having a thirty two thousand dollar car
I've heard you love people for a lot
more a lot less than that
yeah absolutely ridiculous I have a big
problem with cars I have great cars
every year they get more and more
expensive and it just consumes so much
of my life gotcha I got fed up with it
here yeah I hear you had a thirty two
thousand dollar car what I was the rest
of it yeah thirty two thousand dollar
car which I sold for I was only able to
get twenty thousand out of it so I had
twelve thousand remaining from that that
I had to put on signature loans and
credit card
mm-hm and then I had about fifteen
thousand and student loans what were you
driving what kind of car was it it was a
Chevy Volt I sent a picture of it I
don't know if you yes I pulled it up or
not oh they did they put it on the TV
for you you know all right
the and what are you driving now I'm
driving a mm oh ma bought from my
brother for about fifteen hundred
dollars there you go I like that car
it's good a little truck yeah good good
little truck you're right very nice very
nice so what happened dude what happened
twenty two months ago tell me the story
well this actually wasn't my first to go
around with trying to get out of debt I
had tried it a couple years before that
I had bought the financial peace home
kit and I started off really strong
paying off thousands of dollars in
student loans and and whatnot and and I
just completely fell off derailed from
the program and not only did I stop
paying off debt I started getting more
debt again more student loans and I
bought another car I bought a pure
electric car which I got stranded in
three times in a month and a half
the Volt the Volt stranded you not the
Volt actually it was the Nissan Leaf
which was pure electric I got charging
stations were broke broken down all the
time so I upgraded again to an even more
expensive electric car and that with a
gas so you can save money oh yeah and
that's exactly what I did actually yeah
I I'm a big math nerd so I use Excel
spreadsheets and stuff and I justified
it somehow yeah mathematically said if I
Drive this many miles I'm going to save
this much money on gas $4 a gallon yep
and it did not pan out that way at all
so yeah a whole walk in part with the
leaf would bother me yeah oh yeah okay
so what happened 22 months ago then well
I it just the debt was so overwhelming
that it was it was literally like why I
get you know two paychecks a month it
was one of my paychecks and it was it's
pretty ridiculous when your car payment
and insurances hundreds of dollars more
per month than your rent you know and so
I wanted to you know try to pay off the
car originally but then I want us watch
on Kelly Blue Book it was dropping
thousands of dollars a month and value
do not buy an electric car brand new
that's what happens and so it was losing
value a lot quicker and than what I was
paying it off and so the quicker so I
sold it and I only got twenty thousand
out of it and so taking that $12,000
blow was was really heart-wrenching but
you know did you sell it when you
started getting out of debt yeah that
started you 22 months ago back on the
plan that that that's the day I sold
sold the Volt about two years ago from
yesterday okay is the day I start the
actual countdown to getting out of - is
from that point forward that was it for
me
I say I'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired absolutely you had that moment
where you said I've had it
mm-hmm and then you changed and you
became a tightwad oh yeah it's hard not
being in debt anymore and actually being
able to take that extra money that I
would have had before paying on debt and
and actually saving it now for my baby
step 3 so how old are you 26 years old
so what are you a tribute when someone's
listening to you they got a 26 year old
we got a
four-year-old that they're listening to
you right now that was doing the same
dumb things you were doing like I used
to do like most of us used to do and
then you flip this thing on its head and
now you're a champion now you're a hero
what do you tell that young guy out
there that you did what was the secret
to you getting out of debt well I knew
you'd ask that question so I came up
with four things that were absolutely
key the number one was the zero based
budget I did that the first time around
as well but it didn't prevent me from
going back and doing it making the same
mistakes again
my last three reasons are the reasons
that got me back on track and kept me on
track for the for the 22 months that I
did it the second one was immersing my
show or immersing myself into the show
every single day even though 90% of the
information I've heard a million times
because people ask you know who
repetitive questions you can have you
can answer the questions yeah exactly
but that's not what's important what's
important is making that your normal
normal outside is broke but normal
within this atmosphere is is entirely
different and so I made that my normal
by listening to the show every single
day Wow it kept me on track number three
was creating and obtaining a challenging
goal you don't want to set a goal if you
got a twenty thousand dollar a year
income paying off a hundred thousand one
year it's not gonna happen but what I
did at the beginning of 2015 which is
actually where I paid off the majority
of my debt as I set a goal I said I want
to be debt-free by the end of 2015 what
do I need to do to do that you know and
that was another thing I sent a picture
of that goal with it called a dentist
financial peace plan and yeah the
Gazelle chasing the limit very cool so
basically what I did there is I I took
my my debts I listed them I had the
total amount I said okay how many
paychecks do I have for the year divided
that number into that and so that is the
average payment I have to make each each
paycheck to be debt-free by the end of
the year of course I did my monthly
budget but I would have to revise it
based on overtime for every couple of
weeks and you hated earlier yeah I hit
it early and so that was very exciting
and something that kind of helped that
push was I got I got a fortune cookie
which I also
sent a picture of it said three months
from today your lucky star will be
shining and so I said hmm I wonder if I
could pay off my debt in three months
from today and so I redid the math I
said that's a that's a hefty payment but
I managed to do it because I just got a
brand new job at the end of June and I
was working 70 hours a week and so I was
there on a thousand fifteen hundred two
thousand dollars every couple of weeks
at my dad my dad you know it's trying to
tell you what's your minimum payment
this month I confused it because I hid
it so many times you know just destroyed
it ten thousand dollars in the last
three months so everything I could
squeeze out of the budget I couldn't
even get myself to buy a toilet paper
holder host ask your on task I'll tell
you though that's fabulous man yeah so
that was that was number three setting a
goal and tracking it and achieving it
that was huge for me instead of saying I
want to be debt-free sometime in the
future eyes I said I want to be
debt-free by this date what do I need to
do it and so sometimes I'd exceed that
goal sometimes I wouldn't quite get
there and that's okay but I just kept
chucking away at it now number four is
having accountability partners it's
extremely important because it helps
keep you honest to the program I had two
different type of accountability
partners I had ones at work shout out to
the guys that I worked with in my old
job they made fun of me all the time any
time I bought anything I bought a
Domino's Pizza they said Dave approve of
that and and so I had the ones that made
fun of me but I just call them
accountability partners and then I had
the account accountability partners my
family my wonderful fiance Lauren and so
I have that that goal on my refrigerator
and anytime I would walk by or any of my
family they would see that you know I'm
actually doing this and and and watching
me - Lauren was with you who else was
with you these were my parents right
here John and Roberta all right very
cool well Victor I'm very proud of you I
know they are congratulations you gotta
feel it right man you feel great I feel
a million pounds lighter you can do
anything you can do anything you can do
this and that's setting a very specific
goal with a very specific timeline is
very
very important all right Victor from the
Knoxville Tennessee area
technically Sweetwater yeah I know some
stuff and paid off fifty thousand bucks
in twenty two months making twenty seven
to thirty nine thousand a year count it
down brother
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one I'm debt free well done sir
well done yeah shot I had that much
sense when I was twenty six this is the
Dave Ramsey show you guys would be so
rich so fast and be able to do so much
not only for yourselves and for your
family but for others